what is going on reject nation what's
good
guys we are here for the final episode
uh this is the final one of season one
right the last one wow
episode eight where i really come from i
can't wait to check this
out aaron thank you so much for joining
us on this journey
thank you for having me excited to be
here love doing this every week
he's got announcer episode season two
and three hell yeah
so guys hit that like button please it
helps out the algorithm subscribe and
click that notification bell
also as always full length watch alongs
where you sync up with the time code or
over
at our patreon page where we cover a
whole bunch of other shows as well she's
probably mentioned though that
uh we have one of those patreons like a
lot of people where uh when you sign up
it charges right away
and but there's an automatic renewal
charge at the beginning of the first of
every month
so i would you know like wait till
saturday
that way you know get charged up 30th
and then on the first right away and uh
thanks to predominant operating these
highlights for us let's get into action
people
[Music]
you're wearing superman kind of like
representing awning man
and then you know we compare mark to
like spider-man so somewhere in
spider-man
symbolism
okay that's an opening oh
oh wow right away okay it's time for you
to know where i really come from
oh man i am from viltrum but it's
not the planet i've told you about we
have created a perfect
civilization but it took all of our
strength
determination and courage to get there
in order for our people to reach their
full potential
we had to remove the weak from our
society
oh my god but what emerged from the
ashes
was unstoppable by the time i was born
oh my god that was horrible we decided
to make it the only empire in our galaxy
once i was old enough they all had
mustaches
i couldn't tell your mother why i was
here
yeah damn that's a first aid killer and
now
we need to get earth ready to join the
viltrum empire
oh no
you lied to me you couldn't know the
truth you love me
you love mom i know you do
everyone you know and love will be gone
before you even look
30. that's a lot of ambers i do
love your mother but she's
more like a pet
pet this is the only way what
calm down i will not talk now oh my god
this is my life these are my people we
have a responsibility
to build i don't give a [ __ ] about
philtrum and i don't care if i live
i can't let you oh no
no oh my god you have to kind of love
your son dude just a little bit
so be it oh man
oh god
no dude
oh man
i'm gonna guess the fact that his eyes
are still red means it's like it was
like that in the comics
sorry you had to listen to that oh she
heard the whole thing they're slowing
down about 20 miles southeast of chicago
they could afford to sacrifice chicago
well they got pizza
i truly hope mark lives up to his name
to face his father and survive
he'll need to be
[Music]
cool i almost completely read the
letters the phone calls
he grew up as a human dude right you
can't you can't expect him to change
like that
it feels like omniman just went full
tilt in this episode completely dropped
the mask and threw away the costume
[Music]
oh save that man
please don't end up like that old lady
okay good
i was worried for a second thank you
didn't think i was gonna make it
no no
so much effort for what
stop you [ __ ] ass newer can
rely on safety did seeing that man lose
his life disturb you
did it hurt well let's see how you
handle this
god you were such a jerk
he's so mean i kind of believed you
loved your son in the beginning man
ah i think he does have those red eyes
he doesn't
wow wow
it's like a disaster movie yeah
oh man
is that just all from the one punch i
think so
dang omni man that's physical abuse
a little bit just a little bit
oh yeah that would happen oh
man
oh no where's the little girl okay
oh man
just devastating the sound design on
this show
is phenomenal and they threw down for
the animation on this episode
i'm so scared to look
this is like the more real version of
the man of steel fighting yeah
exactly
he's a little zod like how could you do
this totally that was yours
you're stupid that was your fault oh my
god you're
gaslighting and what were they doing
with those fragile little lives
anyway listen to what i'm saying you
know in your heart
i'm right right no you is mom's life
worthless
in the grand scheme oh man
oh man you know who he really reminds me
of
ego from guardians too oh yeah
he's gonna break his [ __ ] arm he's
gonna break his arm okay good
oh my god there's so many people dying
at the expense of this one fight people
are dying
oh my god that's horrible oh my god
horrible oh my god
oh
oh
maybe you were a viltromite when you
came to earth but you've changed
no he hasn't look what he just did is
he's been the whole time
but i'm loyal to viltrum oh
oh my god
um your dad's superman bro
you can't outspeed him
oh my god this is
so heartbreaking burn this planet
down before i spend another minute
living among these
animals oh my god
please
you're only half man
somebody please do something
oh man man the
animation this episode is astounding
it's incredible
the colors just pop some [ __ ] looks real
damn is this whole episode gonna be them
fighting oh
i can't believe you held them through a
train you can't get over that yeah it
was nuts
that was just so so nutty that was so
sadistic
and maybe this is like one of those
power moves in an
injustice right you like god
damn and you like power up and they just
like
do their cinematic clip oh yeah it goes
like around the world and stuff yeah
he's very this is so insane
i just feel hopeless right now watching
this
like what who what are you gonna do
who's gonna who's gonna stop him
you i'm ready when you are oh man
oh my god you want to die for this
planet
fine what 17 more years
i can always start again make another
key
oh my god
jeez dude
oh my god
[Applause]
this is a waste of everyone's time
there's so much more i could be doing
right now
it feels like vegeta in this scene he's
ours
when he feels joy we feel joy
[Applause]
he's so resistant towards the soul
speech it's [ __ ]
oh it's changing not really but
say i want to except a moment uh there's
no redemption for omni man oh no
no none whatsoever
unless he sacrifices himself but that's
about it but even then
barely
did you see that did you see oh that was
amazing
there's so much more attention to detail
the movement of the animation
oh you that's he's like oh
man oh missing tooth still damn it
ah whoa
chin is split open ah i didn't notice
that
why did you make me do this
oh man
oh oh is he's crazy crying oh
[ __ ] man he's definitely crying
right to the camera oh man
oh my god dude he is messed up
dude he's like barely alive
as darkness falls on the day this feels
like a movie
yeah this is damn this is really like
the
epic finale very cinematic this has got
to be one of the greatest superhero
shows ever
yeah it's so so like
so much emotion and so cool at the same
time
someone's emotion it's so cool it's so
authentic to like comic book stories
it hits the realness of consequences and
exactly the responses yeah
exactly realism yeah oh
debbie i'm so proud of you
and don't be alarmed if you see yourself
in mark on the news we send proxies to
the funeral so your lives can go back to
some kind of normal once mark's healed
up
normal i wouldn't be able to live with
myself if i didn't make things as right
as they can be
asked debbie outs
i'd totally have it talking wrong timing
okay
too
that's a beautiful shot look at that
look at them training oh hell yeah
you know that fight was equal parts
disturbing and equal parts cool can't
get over it
it's like it's so awesome it's so
disturbing at the same time
they really earned the emotional weight
of that fight
but it was also excellently uh wow
and animated so many live shattered man
it's gonna be like the world versus omni
man
oh there's gonna be so many people
consoling debbie too
lights whoa
what
[Music]
okay okay shield
oh they're putting it back
cool that's enough lights
we monitored your father until he left
our solar system
he didn't change trajectory so he's
going somewhere pretty damn far away
um which means we um
we need a replacement no
not now not yet um i shouldn't have
brought this up so soon
let's get you and your mother home first
he's being so sensitive
like this you cecil
we fixed the house talk to your school
and debbie's work if either of you need
anything else
you know how to reach me thanks cecil
being so kind
true gray i'm going to go lie down for a
bit
poor debbie why why would you
leave these photos here only she's been
home they said they fixed the home oh
okay they're bad at their job
mom i'm gonna order something for dinner
want to get a pizza
mark
what whoa does this mean uh
looks like i wasn't the only person
being lied to
mark oh that was so touching
oh [ __ ] let's go out oh he's got his
friends
i love no i like their own little friend
group i love it
what is it someone's flying towards
earth from deep space
we're still trying to figure out who it
is but
that's cool
swear some of these backdrops like the
planets look so photorealistic
oh thank you i thought i was too late
when i returned to the coalition of
plans to tell them i'd been going to
earth instead of urath
they lost their minds earth is off
limits there's a filter light living on
your head
what you already know you just left
that's nuts man yeah as far as we can
tell
my dad is just gone that is super weird
for a viltromite
they don't just give up they're
relentless they destroyed my world when
my people rebelled against them
of our planet rather than losing jesus
i'm sorry the coalition is trying to
unite enough worlds to stop the
viltrumite empire the thing is
no one's even heard of a viltromite
abandoning their post
it's insane it just doesn't happen this
could be the advantage we've been
looking for
oh sure once they find out your father
took off the veltromites are going to
come for you
trust me when they set their sights on
the planet the viltrumites
rural
yeah i thought he was running back to
his planet oh
snap
oh they're not destroyed oh
he didn't die there he is oh wow
all the antagonists okay i don't know
who that is
sure that's gonna be important
oh interesting so we're gonna like take
care of other villains
before we get back to nolan yeah oh yeah
this movie this one set up all the
villains
oh oh
now okay finish high school i guess
good that's great yeah
what is high school
wow robert kirkman wrote that episode
wow that was a great episode yeah that
was brilliantly directed
performed written everything about that
that was firing on all cylinders
phenomenal phenomena that was a very
satisfying
phenomenal season one finale and i feel
like any time there's a finale there's
there's that corner of the internet
who's like who's cool with donut or
whatever and maybe
feel away fine i thought that was like a
phenomenal season one finale
yeah i did not feel that way it did a
great job of setting up all these
villains while
dealing with the main thread at hand
that the first episode set up
encapsulated at all
yeah some great tv man phenomenal too so
good i was in love with that i held them
through a train
i bet the train team will be one of the
most talked about like violence oh it's
an episode
it's so shocking because i mean the
second hell now i'm like oh my god he's
going to do exactly what i think he's
going to do with
yeah and like no he's going to get away
with it right like someone's going to
like stop him
right away he puts him up there he's
crashing through the people even though
omniman is the one holding him down mark
is witnessing
like the obliteration of these human
bodies and souls just
right before his eyes and some of them
from directly
landing on him right from the impact and
the force on him it works on so many
like
layers of this is haunting this is
traumatizing
it's also weirdly so cool to look at it
originally so awesome uh yeah i was i
was so
impressed with where they went with it i
loved the fight because
there was so much there was so much
story unveiling
throughout it and also the full-on
complete revelation of
omni man that nolan is he just looks at
himself as a god and the humans are ants
yeah like it's just a crush like they
literally treats them like they're
nothing you know like how man of steel
had like that's part of the conversation
it's like the fight between zod and
superman like how many people freaking
die during that and then here
there is so much focus on that there's
so many bodies just being obliterated
left and right
the whole scene where the building's
falling and he has to choose between
saving the little girl and the mom
but he can't he can't save it all
because he's one person and and
realistically that's about what would
probably happen
because gravity in a falling building
you're not gonna be able to save
everybody there's gonna be so much
destruction they imbued the dna of this
world
so well that they know what to take like
well how would this realistically go
down
this crazy fictional world you know it's
pretty
it's really impressive stuff there's
some feels like there's some real stakes
and consequences like to every breathing
moment
the scene on the train very much kind of
reminded me of something i've seen in
anime
the constant um motion destruction like
walla being from mark's perspective
but yeah this the whole fight it was
equally as equally
devastating as it was really visually
engaging you know
and the fact that we go through a season
we go through these low points of
watching mark and nolan's relationship
grow and watching him idolize his father
and just see him be totally cold and
like we
we saw the progression of that feeling
that mark that nolan wasn't
someone who really cared about people or
like who viewed himself above
everybody else but you really hammer
that home this episode and it's really
devastating because they're like wow
this is the person that mark wanted to
be like you see hints of that
throughout the course of the series him
just releasing that temper you know or
like
be making more selfish decisions or like
feeling like he's above something or
he's a need to do something
you know for him to kind of have that
moment towards the end of the episode
where he's
in his house and he's looking at that
picture of his dad
he has to redefine who he wants to be is
to redefine what it means for him
to be a hero it's my favorite mark
episode handsome
i have a favorite mark episode yeah mark
central and
mark is at the forefront whenever omni
man is on screen he steals the show
of course and you got to get a little
bit more traditional jk simmons
you know enraged not quite my tempo jk
simmons
yeah he didn't go full jade on jameson
but like you saw you saw that anger
i mean but damn the voice acting on like
the voice acting in this epi
when i say this one was firing on all
cylinders it felt like
everything shined everything voice work
i
i've always really liked this episode i
loved it i loved the voice talents here
man
everyone was great yeah the scene that
when you say that
the scene that specifically comes to
mind for me was like after
nolan's just beat the crap out of mark
on the hill or on the mountain
and he's like he's yelling and i'm like
wow like why did you make me do this
you see it both in the animation you
feel it in
in his voice you're like man jk simmons
just acted
all of them are it's so cool what
they've done with like the psychology of
both nolan and mark
because nolan i mean he don't give a
[ __ ] about anyone there's no there's no
redemption for this guy right
like he's he's murdered so many people
he's also murdered probably countless
other beings
it's as established here and he's been
here for 20 years and he's thousands of
years old
this is just a small blip in his in his
life
of course it'd mean nothing to him
you've seen so many things rise and fall
over and over again i love that debate
that that rises from that again
imbued within the psychology of these
characters like mark as you were saying
has always wanted to be his dad yeah
like this is just a
traumatizing epi he didn't just learn oh
my dad killed the guardians
he sees who his dad
really is and this person he aspired to
be his whole like
for such a long time this is this role
model even when he was a little kid and
uh
like even going to that baseball
flashback just you know wanted to make
his dad proud
all that stuff how haunting all this
must be it's just like terrorizing the
soul
nolan it got to the point where i'm like
oh this guy gives a [ __ ] about anything
no and then to have these little
like the littlest moments he's like
flying like i'm
gonna cry
[Laughter]
it was so impactful man i thought the
interesting thing about
omniman was the fact that on viltrum
his society wore white which is like you
know stands for like purity and like
or like uh like sort of sort of angelic
kind of figure you know
and i feel like because half of the
society was
cut because they had to do the survival
of the fittest thing
with superiority as beings they felt
like they had to
kind of lock down their emotions we are
superior we don't feel you know and i
think
maybe that's why nolan is so stoic
because he doesn't
have like a concept of of emotional
development or emotional work through or
know how to handle his emotions
so that's why he's like it was foreign
to him to actually feel something when
he
zoomed off at the end because ah what
are tears those whites don't cry
i can imagine that as living amongst us
and infiltrating and all that like
having to work his way up get to the
guardian so he could eventually kill
them blah blah blah human emotion stuff
that he was feeling
he probably made it maybe chalked it up
as an act to himself
right but then when he was unveiling his
true vulture myself and suddenly the
emotion
i think in those in that moment it was
like oh my god the emotions are real
yeah you know yeah yeah he spent all
this time lying and felt like he was
playing a game but like it actually got
to him
yeah and then he actually was feeling
some stuff that's a great point yeah
yeah i think we i think i nailed it
i think the thing that makes mark
different from his
father is the fact that he has debbie
you know
mark learned like the heroics and the
epics of of
fighting and saving from his dad but he
got his heart from his mom i mean yeah
his whole life he grew up as
as human you know so yeah but just
because you're human doesn't mean you're
not a good person like you still be
human in an [ __ ] true very true
it's like but this whole thing about you
know your vulture might embrace it this
is good why don't you read it come on
man mark
what's your deal man like i mean at
least show them like a visual aid of
vulture might or something
you paid a picture for a minute right
you have something yeah photograph
something to aspire to
here you know you're just talking about
something yeah because it's easy to be
in the audience to be frustrated but
then you gotta remember that
well this is just a blip in time for
nolan right so
it could be difficult for him to be like
dude get it through your head man in
your vulture mind what are you what are
you doing
like you just informed him like he's
going mark's going through a lot but
it's like
nolan has no understanding of just he
really doesn't comprehend human emotion
right so even when he starts to feel
emotion he gets so
flustered and angry and confused and
you know even going to that baseball
scene like he couldn't have such a hard
time just like
being here for his kid and watching his
kid play baseball
but then when he gives it like there are
these human tendencies but they do push
him to the point where i'm like you can
never redeem this guy to be a good
person
but there is you do have those shades of
hope also i love how like the first half
of this episode
is dedicated to revelations to fight i
love the details of the vulture my world
i love how it's just boiled down to
something so
sinisterly basic everyone's been looking
for a big purpose
for why he killed the guardians there's
gotta be a reason
i don't know i just wanna keep someone
conquered
it'll take over the world oh that's it
damn
execution execution that makes it
killer it's unsettling but what i love
was that the last half it
it focuses on the heartbreak of knowing
this
right down to from like just everyone
like the world having to deal with
omniman being actually evil the world's
greatest hero was actually
the world's greatest threat and then you
know of course debbie
and even cecil you know cecil and uh the
other guardians like have
watching them but then you're also
getting this like weird melancholy sense
of hope
that through omniman being the world's
greatest
enemy that there might be more of a
unity
yeah yeah yeah they're because earth's
lost his greatest
uh defender or protector the the rest of
the hero community has to step up has to
come together because there are greater
threats
and we don't know if the world or if
they're gonna disclose
the conversation or what what nolan's
true intentions are
to the public or not with mark knowing
and with uh with alan alien coming
they're going to make more of a
conscious effort
to bring people together because i feel
like a war is coming
that's kind of a little bit of the
impression that i had yeah i said
vulture mites
you know yeah oh man i just want to read
the comics but i also
love the surprise
because like it might still like i feel
like the it's like a double-edged sword
because like you you
you take away the surprise of enjoying
the show you get to know all the content
yeah
yeah yeah i'm like oh i want to read it
but damn it i love being surprised and i
love the revelations here
and also there's the taylor again that
not the taylor the guy makes the suits
uh aj or something like that mark
campbell or camel right
yeah i really appreciate them dealing
with the devastation
of not just the physical consequences of
the fight but also
the the revelation of omni man you know
like
debbie's had had to deal with so much i
felt so much for her and i love the way
they portrayed her that she cries in
private
yeah but just be strong for her son
strong for her son she's strong around
other people she's a strong character
like she
reserves her tears when she's alone
she's around other people she's
she like she has to bottle that up
and do and do what has to be done so i
think like that's a great way to write a
character that's a great way to write i
like your character make her
strong but vulnerable and the right
moments yeah then like amber come back i
love the
the hope of they come together as
friends in the end
amber mark amber
academy if that's your name william is
that his name william
got their own little friend group i love
it it managed to have a little bit of
this like
hopeful quality in the end surprisingly
yeah
yeah and they better have broken his
character too yeah
yeah ellen the alien coming back i feel
like we're gonna see more of him
definitely going forward
well it seems like what they're doing
with season two is building up the
anticipation for when nolan would return
this is what i'm thinking i don't know
and then we'll be taking care of these
other villains that we've also
established
yeah in this in this season so far that
we haven't really
gone back to but if
mark can successfully defeat that it
could be a way for him to build
exactly and whoever else works with them
then build up to taking on
the big baddie it's like going through
bad guy levels in a video game before
using the big boss
yeah yeah yeah omni level omni man was
like like level 500
and mark was like level 12 and he got
the [ __ ] kicked out of him but by the
time he meets his dad again he's gonna
be on par
it's gonna be super epic i really
sincerely think this was an amazing ass
episode i really think from
even just the technical standpoints i
mean we said a lot during the reaction
that i feel like is
just there you know like right dennis
cecil showing the more sensitive side
the more caring side to him i like how
amber does come back
yeah i like the way she came back and i
loved the reveal of adam eve i love the
way they
and they handled that of what adam tells
them but yeah i think in the last
a lot of the morning grieving areas up
here you saw a lot of just care and
heart there but i really feel like on a
technical aspect
this was the best the show looked and
felt and was
stylized like a lot of the landscapes
and the background images like with when
they're
like fighting in the clouds like the
attention to detail on the clouds
look like equivalent to a live-action
fight in the sky when it's executed well
you know
yeah the show does this thing where like
he has this traditional animation style
that we've come accustomed to but then
it'll just like
throw its money like look at this
beautiful shot
look at the moon look at this city like
look at this explosion
you know i'm happy that um it does have
that variety
i i watched an interview with um with
robert kirkman no not robert kirkman
what's the
creator of the show i was right robert
kirkman
and he said that one of the anim one of
the
artists from the comic was brought on to
the show to help
kind of the animation team this is his
first time he's ever animated anything
that influence from how he did the art
and the comic to
the show is why it has such a unique
flavor to it i think it's
done so so like striking is the word
that keeps coming to mind
even the way they did the editing like
the energy the pace the whip cuts
the whip pans like so it was so i was in
awe
yeah like wow this is so visually this
beautifully
realized in every way oh and also uh the
guardians becoming a team
yeah yeah it was very satisfying also
rudy is in the robot suit now it's not a
droid
in it like iron man that was cool but
that's what i meant about like how
having this enemy is bringing can create
a bigger sense of unity for some people
because i feel like even some bad guys
will be like that omni man's a threat we
got to work together
yeah yeah you know zayn those vulture
might that history that's some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] yeah yeah
uh we gotta take care of those guys
there's
evil sons and [ __ ] out there they're
going to kill us
i love this one um absolutely
absolutely brilliant absolutely
brilliant that's all i got today man
that was that was incredible guys what'd
you think of this finale leave your
thoughts down below aaron thanks for
being here thank you everyone who's
followed us on patreon speaking of which
last but not least
colin anderson you're the last patron of
the day shout out for the month buddy
and colin anderson i've talked to this
guy quite a bit on social media over the
past like i want to say a year
and this guy has a life that i want
he is constantly traveling like one of
his main passion is to travel and go on
these adventurous nature filled hikes
could be in the snow it could be in like
in the forest areas like he sends
pictures and i'm just envious and hating
him
and why i go all vulture mind on him you
know i just keep wanting to thrash him
to death out of my pure envy
but then i remember no no
he's a patron and uh we appreciate the
pledge
if he goes we lose the pledge so
i hope you're here to keep living your
life i hope you get to travel a lot more
this year
and yeah you're you're an inspiration a
lot of ways man so thank you for being
you dude
and uh right on i don't know if you
okay all right it's okay i was gonna say
a thing that
they might be you know don't think you
did you did it
i'm proud of you i'm proud of you
what was his name again
steve colin anderson
colin anderson you're a star